how have those conversations been going
what are the things that she's asking
you about and how do you respond to it i
mean they're hard
they're hard conversations of course
she's asking me about my past
she's wondering why you know i'm not
there you know for certain times of
course
and to try to explain things for me is
it hurts me
but as a mother i i have to be a mother
and
i have to be be the adult and then and
this conversation in the conversation
and try to explain it the best way that
i can he wants me to live on his land
in a trailer are you being serious right
now don't want to
go to therapy it's time to move the
floor
you know fans are so excited to watch
both of your
families and the journeys behind the ups
and downs of life
macy i want to start with you i have a
few questions of course about what we're
going to see this season
with your family as you co-parent with
ryan and your husband
what can we expect you can expect a lot
with bentley and his relationship with
his dad
and him making very healthy wise
beyond his years decisions and working
to better
his relationship with himself and with
his dad
obviously my two littles just being
adorable
and wild and parenting through a
pandemic
i can't imagine that that's easy but you
know you bring up bentley being
wise beyond his years and so mature i'm
just curious for you macy you know
there's so many headlines in the press
about your back and forth with ryan how
does that make you feel how do you
navigate um what you're doing in your
personal life
playing out in such a massively public
way
i don't like look at social media or
read any of the tabloids so
i'm not really sure but i mean we've
always kind of kept
the side drama like away
if that makes sense um what you see on
the show is
is really like what goes on and
sometimes in the tabloids or in the
press
it's correct and sometimes it is a
hundred percent
not correct i want to give you the
opportunity you know as i was
researching for this interview i did see
a few headlines about
the status of your marriage with taylor
i want to give you the opportunity to
clear the air and set the record
straight on how you and taylor are doing
we are doing great we're not getting a
divorce or anything i swear
i think they got tired of saying that i
was pregnant again so they came up with
something else
well i'm happy to hear that you guys are
doing well amber i want to move on
to you and ask you of course what can we
expect from you
in teen mom og season 9. you're going to
see a lot of growth that you're probably
going to see a well of the person that
probably never seen before and more wise
i mean i don't know they're gonna edit
it
i've just educated myself on things that
i didn't know before and you know i
thought i did
i think that's just growth and wisdom um
and you know honestly
it's hectic because i have quick life at
the moment i think everybody knows that
obviously
it's been out it's gone out in the media
for quite some time and
uh you're just gonna have to watch and
see how do you think you've changed in
the last
you know maybe maybe year or so as you
said you've kind of gone on this journey
of growth
what made you want to learn and grow and
how do you think you've changed
i had already been before honestly i've
always been
this there's a certain thing hopefully
they this year that we touched
on i've always been into reading
philosophy writing
uh music things like that something that
has never really been put on
this show um you know educating myself
through just many different things and
everything's connected honestly good
energy
is what i want to surround myself with
and not
bad i spiritually and
i have grown it has been a great change
for the last few years of my life
and a greater change for the last couple
years of my life honestly well that's
wonderful to hear
i cannot believe that your oldest is now
my goodness is she 13 little ones now
with technology and the ipads and
they have access to to the internet i'm
curious how
as as leah gets older and starts to
learn more
about you know her family and your very
public life
how will you approach conversations with
her about everything you've been through
the highs and the lows
lea is very savvy with that kind of
stuff she's very smart straight student
i'm very proud of her she has a lot of
questions i've answered as many as i can
that i feel is appropriate for her age
it's going gonna be hard because you
know the woes that i've been through in
life
she's not gonna understand until she's
probably a little bit
older there's some things that she can
understand you know it's my job as as a
mother
to be there and to just open my uh my
mouth and and
really let her know it's okay to ask me
the questions
in the appropriate manner and you know
and really speak to me and be open about
it
no i really didn't expect it to be this
early you know but
um she's the her years we still love
each other we still have a good
relationship
it's just you know she answered she has
questions she wants to know why
you know she ain't she has some probably
anger i'm guessing
a majority for something that's okay
um i you know let me i want to hear it i
want to i want to be able to answer
those questions for her and make her
feel
a bit better about certain situations
instead of just bottling it up inside i
don't think that's healthy for her
you know we really need to have that
bond back that
i've been striving for and i think that
that's something that's been um
deteriorated uh because of certain
things has happened
in life you know on my end how have
those conversations been going what are
the
the things that she's asking you about
and how do you respond to it the hard
conversations of course she's asking me
about my past
you know she's wondering why you know
i'm not there you know for certain times
of course
and to try to explain things for me is
it hurts me
but as a mother i i have to be
a mother and i have to be be the adult
and
and this conversation the conversation
and try to explain it the best way that
i can but also i have to remember who
ate
i have to remember that you know there's
things that she'll she'll find out more
when she gets older
she's smart she'll as she gets older
she'll learn more and
we'll grow together and that's what's
gonna that's
what i'm looking forward to just growing
together with her because yeah we have
had a hard
time you know i've had a hard life in
the beginning and now it's time to grow
from that
well i love that you seem to be in a
great place today and focused on all the
healthy things
give me the kisses your mommy good
sugars
no like this i cannot believe that that
you've been part of this franchise
for over a decade at this point and so
many moments have have been captured on
the show
if you could pinpoint one moment that
you wish you could take back
do differently not have the cameras
there what would that specific moment be
being on the show is like a blessing and
a curse like
yes there are definitely things that
you're like oh my god what was i
thinking why did i do that
but at the the blessing part is that you
can see yourself
and learn from it you're like oh
i don't want to do that again i don't
like how i was behaving or i don't
like how i was treating someone or um
stuff like that so it's it's a useful
tool actually it's like therapy you get
to see it
nobody likes people they get to see
themselves
going through the hardest parts of their
lives literally physically
and that's what yes gets you
um that's where the blessing comes in
and respects
for sure yeah does any one moment in
particular stand out
obviously me uh going to prison was
probably one of the best things that
could have ever happened to me that i
probably wouldn't be here today that's
just
the truth of the matter
you